[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbwegs guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann als mutter von mir und
wir haben unter anderem diese themen für
sie
hitzige debatte im bundestag das
parlament streitet in einer
sondersitzung über die afghanistan krise
im chaos von kabul versuchen weiter
tausende auf einen flieger zu gelangen
straßen- schienen- brücken in den
zerstörten flut regionen wird geprüft wo
für die 30 milliarden euro staatshilfe
am dringendsten gebraucht werden
[Musik]
jubelschrei bei den paralympics die bahn
radfahrerin denise schindler gewinnt mit
bronze in tokio die erste medaille aller
nationen
eigentlich wären die
bundestagsabgeordneten noch in der
sommerpause doch zu vieles drängt corona
die flutkatastrophe und vor allem der
evakuierungseinsatz in afghanistan die
opposition spricht vom schwärzesten
punkt in merkels 16-jähriger
kanzlerschaft merkel selbst räumt fehler
ein bemerkt aber auch im nachhinein
bewertungen abzugeben sei nicht wirklich
kompliziert patricia wiedemeier
bitte furchtbar und eine tragödie sei
die lage in afghanistan
die künstlerin zeigte sich in ihrer
regierungserklärung sichtlich betroffen
und enttäuscht merkel erklärte der
20-jährige einsatz sei nicht umsonst
gewesen die entwicklung habe man aber
falsch eingeschätzt wir alle zusammen
die werden afghanistan engagiert worden
also die gesamte internationale
koalition
wir alle haben die geschwindigkeit
dieser entwicklung ganz offensichtlich
unterschätzt und das gilt auch für
deutschland
jetzt gehe es darum noch möglichst viele
menschen zu evakuieren und möglichst
viel von dem was man erreicht habe zu
bewahren sie scheue nicht davor zurück
darüber auch mit den taliban zu sprechen
auch die spd hält gespräche mit den
taliban für notwendig zudem dankte der
fraktionsvorsitzende den soldaten die in
afghanistan ihr leben riskieren
die situation in afghanistan bleibt auch
in diesen stunden
brandgefährlich wir danken den
bundeswehr soldaten für den noch nicht
abgeschlossenen rettungseinsatz für sie
entscheiden wir heute über die
rechtssicherheit der notwendigen
maßnahmen die opposition kritisierte die
regierung heftig linke grüne und fdp
fordern aufarbeitung durch einen
untersuchungsausschuss nach der
bundestagswahl und personelle
konsequenzen danach brauchen wir
aufarbeitung und konsequenzen auch
personelle die daran beteiligt waren
sollten nie wieder mitglieder einer
bundesregierung seien die letzten tage
und wochen haben den eindruck
organisierte unverantwortlichkeit
verstärkt und das muss folge für die
sicherheitspolitik unseres landes haben
das bedeutet ein afghanistan gipfel
jetzt einzuberufen an dem natürlich alle
nato-staaten beteiligt sind die
anrainerstaaten damit wir über die
unterstützung im land leben können die
fdp warnt vor einer zweiten
flüchtlingswelle der einsatz in
afghanistan sei ein großer fehler
gewesen um geschlechtergerechtigkeit in
die muslimische welt zu tragen mussten
deutsche männer dort ihr leben lassen
wie viele afghanische frauen in höchsten
ämtern oder mädchen in schulen
eigentlich einen deutschen toten
soldaten auch mit großer mehrheit
billigte der bundestag nachträglich den
evakuierungseinsatz der bundeswehr ein
einsatz der schon ende der woche zu ende
gehen dürfte
theo koll in berlin es soll die erste
ausführliche stellungnahme der kanzlerin
zu den vorwürfen rund um afghanistan
warum hat die regierung den aus kräften
dort mich früher geholfen
und angela merkel beschrieb das heute
als dilemma wenn man zusammen mit der
bundeswehr gleich auch alle mitarbeiter
und ortskräfte deutscher
hilfsorganisationen abgezogen hätte dann
wäre das zwar für einige
vorrausschauende
vorsicht gewesen sagte sie für andere
aber ein signal dass man das land
komplett im stich lässt man habe nach
dem abzug des militärs den menschen
zumindest in der entwicklungsarbeit
weiter helfen wollen bei strom- und
wasserversorgung genauso wie bei der
gesundheitsversorgung die folge davon
ist aber dass jetzt viele dieser
ortskräfte in der falle sitzen wie kann
und will die regierung den menschen denn
jetzt helfen wenn die evakuierung zu
ende ist
ich fürchte dass die deutsche luftbrücke
früher als dienstag zu ende gehen wird
denn die bundeswehr kann kaum mit der
gesamten logistik auf den letzten
drücker den flughafen verlassen das
dürfte eher gestaffelt und dann früher
passieren die verteidigungsministerin
sprache eben von einer evakuierungs
phase 2 über die verhandler man gerade
in doha mit den taliban dazu passte auch
die kanzlerin heute erwähnte man
versuche zusätzliche andere rettungswege
zu schaffen unter anderem durch einen
zivilen betrieb des flughafens in kabul
und zusätzlich will die regierung
humanitäre hilfe leisten und dem man
sowohl die arbeit der vereinten nationen
vor ort finanziell unterstützt als auch
die nachbarländer und angesichts der
sich verschlechternde versorgungslage
könnte das sogar ein angebot sein auf
dass die taliban dann eingehen vielen
dank für diese information live aus
berlin von theo koll
jetzt beginnen für uns die
anspruchvollsten und auch die
gefährlichsten stunden heißt es aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
gemeint ist das bevorstehende ende der
evakuierungen mit militärmaschinen die
lage am flughafen kabul bleibt
gefährlich und chaotisch tausende
drängen sich am zaun und hoffen rein
gelassen zu werden und auf einen flieger
zu kommen der sie in sicherheit bringt
nach angaben des auswärtigen amtes
halten sich noch mehr als 200 deutsche
in kabul auf was genau sich am flughafen
abspielt es nach wie vor schwer
einzuschätzen unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf steht seit tagen in kontakt
zur betroffenen in kabul die ihr immer
wieder berichten von ihren verzweifelten
versuchen rauszukommen
es ist eine von so vielen nachrichten
die mich in diesen tagen vom flughafen
kabul erreichen
wir warten seit drei tagen ja aber es
klappt nicht für uns wir warten nur
darauf dass das tor öffnet
ganz kurz erscheint das gesicht der
jungen frau verschwommen in der
dunkelheit dann bricht der kontakt
wieder ab
ein handy-video schickt mir ein
afghanischer journalist im hintergrund
wird geschossen mit seiner frau und drei
kleinen kindern sucht er nach deutschen
soldaten die sie in den flughafen lassen
es ist sehr gefährlich für kinder
zweimal habe ich meine kinder verloren
sie haben uns mit tränengas beschossen
das feuer eröffnet
am abend erreiche ich die junge
sportlerin sie hält sich inzwischen bei
verwandten versteckt
es geht mir nicht gut es tut mir leid
ich kann nicht reden ihre
mannschaftskolleginnen haben es heraus
geschafft nach frankreich in die usa die
letzte hoffnung ist jetzt eine
sicherheitsfirma die versuchen will
morgen eine weitere gruppe zum flughafen
zu bringen die zeit wird knapp und der
weg zum flughafen für afghanen immer
schwieriger nur noch wenige tage will
die bundeswehr noch menschen aus der
afghanischen hauptstadt ausfliegen ich
bin sicher es wird noch viele hilferufe
geben aus kabul
mehr zur gefährlichen flucht aus kabul
sehen sie im auslandsjournal um 22 uhr
im bundestag ging es heute auch um den
wiederaufbau vor für die
hochwassergebiete im westen 30
milliarden euro wollen bund und länder
dafür bereitstellen sechs wochen ist es
her dass die wassermassen ganze
landstriche regelrecht verwüstet haben
mehr als 180 menschen kamen ums leben
der wiederaufbau wird jahre dauern was
es dabei zu bedenken gilt und was jetzt
am nötigsten ist berichtet christopher
heinze aus dem besonders betroffenen
aartal
rund 750.000 euro veranschlagt jürgen
schwarzmann bürgermeister von hönningen
für die uferbefestigung samt neuer
straße gebaut wird bereits das geld soll
dann möglichst bald aus dem wiederaufbau
vorkommen mit viel ehrenamtlicher hilfe
wurde in den vergangenen wochen die
infrastruktur hier wieder notdürftig
hergestellt strom funktioniert was wir
gesagt haben wir noch ein problem hier
installiert wir haben noch einen
straßenzug der noch keine wasserleitung
hat aber auch dass mit hochdruck daran
gearbeitet und ich denke auch dass ich
hoffe mal dass in dieser woche dann auch
diese straße damit abschließen können
momentan laufen die arbeiten im aartal
überall parallel es wird geräumt
repariert und renoviert die milliarden
aus dem wiederaufbau fonds sollen sowohl
an die öffentliche hand als auch an
privatpersonen gehen erwartung der
menschen vor ort
dass das geld auch tatsächlich ankommt
wir packen alle zusammen und ich denk
gemeinsam schaffen wir sehen jetzt
neubau der guckt sich treff ganz genau
an wo er dann hin bauen möchte fachleute
fordern ein gesamtkonzept das nicht nur
den schnellen wiederaufbau beinhaltet
viel sinnvoller wäre es meines erachtens
sich die gebiete im oberlauf der
anzusehen und dort mit relativ
kostengünstigen maßnahmen
diese flächen zu schaffen dass das
wasser ausweichen kann ein gesamtkonzept
steckt derzeit noch in beratung
gleichzeitig werden vor ort fakten
geschaffen bei bürgermeister schwarzmann
und allen anderen sollen die ersten
zahlungen aus dem wiederaufbau fonds in
den kommenden wochen ankommen
zum thema corona gibt es noch immer eine
so genannte epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite
darüber will der bundestag heute noch
entscheiden wenn ja kann der bund weiter
ohne zustimmung der länder regeln
erlassen etwa zu tests impfungen oder
der einreise kritik kommt aus der
opposition auch weil die lage in den
krankenhäusern nach wie vor eher
entspannt ist und so sehen die aktuellen
corona zahlen aus das robert koch
institut meldet 11.500 61 neue
infektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden das
sind
3237 mehr als am vergangenen mittwoch
wenn eines tages kamen 39 todesfälle
hinzu die sieben tage incidents steigt
auf
61,3
auch beim impfen gibt es neue zahlen
mehr als 100 millionen dosen wurden
inzwischen in deutschland verabreicht
knapp 60 prozent der bevölkerung sind
vollständig geimpft allerdings
infizieren sich vereinzelt auch geimpfte
mit corona wie oft kommt es zu solchen
impft durchbrüchen und wen trifft es
mehr dazu finden sie bei zdf heute und
in unserer app
fast fünf milliarden euro im ersten
halbjahr das ist der umsatz der
computerspielindustrie in deutschland
eine wachsende branche auch durch corona
weltweit wichtigster treffpunkt für die
entwickler und die fans ist die gamescom
in köln digital wie die spiele ist auch
die messe in pandemie zeiten andreas
garbe zeigt dass die neuheiten nicht nur
spaß machen sollen sondern auch immer
politischer werden in videospielen die
auf der digitalen gamescom gezeigt
werden geht es neuerdings um guerilla
kampf um flüchtlingsströme und schlepper
klimakatastrophen bürgerkriege aus immer
öfter polarisieren games mit politik und
haltung für den branchenverband beweis
einer zunehmenden kulturellen relevanz
und verjüngung des mediums die
entwicklung dass häufig auch politische
themen spielen aufgegriffen werden dass
das stärker wird hat sicher auch damit
zu tun dass mehr menschen gerade auch
jüngere die als kreative nachkommen sich
ausdrücken wollen den spielen ein
deutscher spieleverlag drückt sich
besonders deutlich aus thematisiert in
seinen spielen etwa kritisch das
abrutschen in die neonazi-szene
ich bin die die sika
aufkäufer vom rechten rand und rassisten
könnte man gern verzichten ob dann der
eine oder andere unser spiel nicht
kauffeld wirtschaftlichen bilanz nicht
mehr auf von daher kann man auch leuten
deutlich sagen wie man haben möchte auch
welche werte man wichtig findet
medienwissenschaftler sehen die
videospielebranche in einem
tiefgreifenden umbruch wie es ihn im
kino schon in den 70er jahren gab
soziale randgruppen und auch
gesellschaftliche verhältnisse die sonst
nicht in film thematisiert wurden die
rückten auf einmal in den mittelpunkt
des interesses
und das ist etwas wo glaubst gerade die
spiele die jetzt stärker in den
independent bereich gehen ähnliche
strategien wählen können videospiele
seien in der mitte der gesellschaft
angekommen heißt es oft aus der branche
an den rändern grenzt sich das medium
aber immer mehr ab
die musikwelt und millionen von fans
trauern um charlie watts schlagzeuger
der rolling stones mit diesem foto
reagierte frontmann mick jagger auf den
tod seines bandkollegen ohne jeden
weiteren kommentar gitarrist keith
richards veröffentlichte dieses bild von
watts einsamem schlagzeug auf der bühne
charlie watts war gestern im alter von
80 jahren gestorben aus london andreas
stamm
charlie watts der ruhende pol der
rock'n'roll band schlechthin fast sechs
jahrzehnte der taktgeber im hintergrund
[Musik]
ohne viel pathos leise würde voll so wie
es ihm entspricht verabschieden sich im
internet weggefährten wie ringo starr
oder elton john der ihn als stilikone
und großartigen begleiter würdigt
ein fantastischer schlagzeuger ein feld
der brandung ich liebe dich charlie für
immer du bist ein wundervoller mensch
die frontmänner mick jagger und keith
richards definierten und lebten sex
drugs and rock'n roll während sie
hotelzimmer zerlegten zeichnete der
gelernte grafiker watts lieber im
nebenraum der star rummel
stadionkonzerte welttourneen sein leben
nicht seine welt
ich kann ja nicht alleine zuhause
trommeln ich muss auf tour und dafür
muss ich mein zuhause verlassen das ist
der teufelskreis in dem sich mein leben
ewig
watts große liebe der jazz club konzerte
mit anderen bandprojekten und shirley
mit der er seit 1964 verheiratet war in
den achtzigern familien und
drogenprobleme er fing sich schnell
blieb bis zuletzt der gentleman trommler
voller grazie und coolness nach
überstandener op wollte der 80-jährige
eigentlich wieder mit der band auf tour
gehen als der den laden menschlich und
musikalisch immer zusammen
norbert zum sport zu den paralympics in
tokio wo es am ersten wettkampftag auch
die erste deutsche medaille gab bronze
für radsportlerin denise schindler auf
der straße war sie ja schon
weltmeisterin und dreimal bei den
paralympics erfolgreich jetzt ihre erste
medaille auf der bahn in der 3000 meter
verfolgung in persönlicher bestzeit
gewinnt denise schindler den kampf um
platz drei und damit die erste medaille
der spiele dank sehr fokussierter
leistung ich bin so erleichtert ich war
also ein tunnel ich war für kein
ansprechbar heute und jetzt sah es aus
die seit einem unfall als kind
unterschenkelamputierte sportlerin
startet mit einer von ihr selbst mit
entwickelten prothese schindler lässt in
bronze rennen die us-amerikanerin klarer
brown hinter sich um gut sechs sekunden
im kino velodrom bleibt die 35 jährige
diplom betriebswirtin aus cottbus unter
dem weltrekord aber außer ihr auch die
beiden finalistinnen gold holt die
australierin petrenko forscher um wang
aus china
zum goalball das ist eine bei sport für
menschen mit sehbehinderung da sind die
deutschen männer gold favorit aber
hatten heute große mühen beim
auftaktspiel gegen die türkei zunächst
eine klare 14 0 führung dann wurde der
gegner immer stärker beim spielstand von
5 04 entschied ein penalty für
deutschland das spiel michael denn ist
verwandelt zum 6 4-endstand
zum fussball heute abend das letzte
spiel der ersten runde im dfb-pokal und
da trifft ein ganz kleiner auf einen
ganz großen fünftligist bremer sv auf
bayern münchen beim umzug ins weser
stadion eigentlich spielstätte des sv
werder
gänsehautmomente für den fünftligisten
bremer sv ii ist die taktik für das
spiel
zeigen dass sie auch fussball spielen
können wollen mutig spielen wollen
unsere chance auch nach vorne suchen
gegner bayern münchen und manuel neuer
torjäger robert lewandowski und leon
goretzka bayern trainer julian
nagelsmann rechnet trotzdem mit einem
sieg das ein underdog natürlich da
wahrscheinlich noch ein tick mehr laufen
wird als vielleicht in einer eigenen
liga spielen körperlich wie gesagt
kannst du immer total dagegen natürlich
anstellen und feierten und da hoffen wir
uns einstellen und am ende ja natürlich
das spiel gewinnen und das haben auch
vor der underdog aus bremen hofft auf
einen achtungserfolg auch war bayern
münchen ohne einige topstars antritt
ja und mehr sport mit ausführlichen
berichten von den paralympics später im
heute journal ein grund mehr zur guckt
nach dankeschön fehlen noch die
lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten 6 9
11 12 24
33 und die superzahl 7
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
letzte nacht gab es den ersten
bodenfrost in diesem spätsommer technik
bringt jetzt auch noch wolken und regen
die details hat gleich katja horneffer
claus kleber begrüßt sie um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal und hier übernimmt
morgen jana vereins danke für ihr
interesse alles gute ihnen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend gestern hatte sich ja
bereits angedeutet tatsächlich hat der
akku rallye heute 27 grad und damit war
es mit vollen unterstützung auf island
genau so warm wie an der adria unsere
kalt von macht sich auch bemerkbar
hinter der kaltfront lagen die
temperaturen am nachmittag nur bei 17
davor immer noch bei 23 grad und die
kaltfront zieht im laufe der nacht
weiter nach süden regnet es vor allen
dingen rund um die mittelgebirge aber
auch in berlin dahinter lockern die
wolken schon wieder auf und hier in
süddeutschland da verschwindet der
klaren sternenhimmel mehr und mehr
hinter wolken deswegen wird es in der
nacht auch nicht mehr ganz so kalt wie
in der vergangenen da gab es ja den
ersten bodenfrost im erzgebirge diesem
spätsommer heute nachts sinken die werte
auf sieben oder acht grad im südwesten
und am alpenrand sonst bleibt es bei 15
bis 10 grad etwas milder und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen zwischen
15 und 19 grad und nur auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und dem rheintal
gibt so 20 bis 22 grad der regen der
nacht kommt morgen auch am alpenrand an
dahinter lockern die wolken etwas
ausgibt kräftige schauer im nordosten
auch gewitter richtung westen wird ein
bisschen freundlicher und auch in den
nächsten tagen geht es sehr wechselhaft
weiter wir bleiben einfach in dieser
nordwestströmung guten abend